este problema dicen construye la
bisectriz para el ángulo dado aquí está
el ángulo del cual hablan y lo que
quieren que hagamos es construir una
recta que parta este ángulo a la mitad
una recta que pase por este vértice y
corte a este ángulo en dos ángulos
iguales dos ángulos que miden la mitad
del ángulo original bueno para hacer eso
lo primero que vamos a hacer es
construir un punto aquí y un punto acá
que sean equidistantes al vértice y para
eso voy a tomar el compás lo voy a
centrar en el vértice y podría poner
cualquier radio los puntos van a ser los
puntos de intersección de este círculo o
de la orilla del círculo con estos rayos
vale entonces va a ser este punto y este
punto de acá ok entonces voy a poner
otros puntos uno por aquí y voy a poner
otro punto por acá
por acá
ahí está y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
construir la media tris entre este es
este punto de aquí y este punto de acá y
para hacer eso pues simplemente hacemos
los pasos que ya habíamos hecho antes
tomamos este círculo el compás y hacemos
que tenga radio igual a la distancia
entre estos dos puntos es decir igual a
la longitud del segmento y de manera
similar este círculo de acá lo que
hacemos es centrarlo en este punto y
tomar el radio igual a la distancia a la
distancia a la longitud de este segmento
y con esto tenemos dos puntos el de acá
que es el vértice y el de acá que es
otro punto que al unirlos se forma la
bisectriz deseada déjame unir los voy a
poner este punto por acá y voy a poner
este punto por acá
ahí está más o menos y entonces aquí
podrías preguntarte por qué esta recta
porque esto es una bisectriz bueno pues
vamos a utilizar el criterio lado lado
lado en este triángulo el formado por
estos tres puntos y estos tres puntos si
te das cuenta este lado es igual a este
lado porque este radio es igual a este
radio que es igual a este radio este
lado de manera similar es igual a este
lado porque dijimos que estos dos radios
son iguales y finalmente los dos
triángulos comparten este segmento de
acá por lo tanto son triángulos
congruentes y entonces este ángulo es
igual a este ángulo por ser ángulos
correspondientes de esta forma se
muestra que la línea que trazamos es una
bisectriz